what we have written here are two of the
most useful derivatives to know in
calculus if you know that the derivative
of sine of x with respect to x is cosine
of x and the derivative of cosine of x
with respect to x is negative sine of x
that can empower you to do many more far
more complicated derivatives but what
we're going to do in this video is dig a
little bit deeper and actually prove
this first
derivative i'm not going to prove the
second one you can actually use it using
the information we're going to do in
this one but it's just to make you feel
good that someone's just not making this
up that there is a little bit of
mathematical rigor behind it all
so let's try to calculate it so the
derivative with respect to x of sine of
x
by definition this is going to be the
limit as delta x
approaches 0
of sine
of x plus
delta x
minus
sine of x
all of that over
delta
all of that over delta x this is really
just the slope of the line between the
point
x comma sine of x and x plus delta x
comma sine of x plus delta x
so how can we evaluate this
well we can rewrite
sine of x plus delta x
using our angle addition formulas that
we learned during our trig identities so
this is going to be the same thing
as the limit
as delta x
approaches zero
i'll write rewrite this using our trig
identity as cosine
as cosine
of x
times sine
of delta x
plus
sine
of x times cosine of delta x and then
we're going to subtract this sine of x
up here minus sine of x
all of that over let me see if i can
draw a relatively straight line all of
that over
delta x
so this can be rewritten as being equal
to the limit
as delta x approaches 0
of
let me write this part
in red
so that would be cosine of x sine
of delta x
all of that over
delta x
and then that's going to be plus i'll do
all of this in orange
all i'm doing is i have the sum of
things up here divided by delta x i'm
just breaking it up a little bit
plus
sine
of x cosine of delta x
minus sine
of x
all of that
over delta x and remember i'm taking the
limit of this entire expression well the
limit of a sum is equal to the sum of
the limits so this is going to be equal
to
i'll do this first part in red
the limit
as delta x approaches 0 of let's see i
can rewrite this as
cosine of x
times sine
of delta x
over delta x
plus
the limit
as delta x approaches 0
of and let's see i can factor out a sine
of x here so it's times
sine
of x
i factor that out and i'll be left with
a cosine
of delta x minus 1
all of that over
delta
x
so that's this limit and let's see if i
can simplify this even more let me
scroll down a bit
so this left hand expression i can
rewrite this cosine of x has nothing to
do with the limit as delta x approaches
0 so we can actually take that outside
of the limit so we have the cosine of x
times the limit
as delta x approaches 0
of sine of delta x
over delta x
and now we need to add this thing and
let's see how i could write this so i
have a sine of x here actually let me
rewrite this a little bit differently
cosine of delta x minus 1 that's the
same thing as 1 minus cosine of delta x
times
negative 1. and so you have a sine of x
times a negative 1 and since the delta x
has nothing to do with the sine of x let
me take that out the negative and the
sine of x so we have minus
sine of x
times the limit
as delta x approaches 0 of what we have
left over is 1 minus cosine
of delta x
over
delta x
now i'm not going to do it in this video
in other videos we will actually do the
proof but in other videos we have shown
using the squeeze theorem or sometimes
known as the sandwich theorem that the
limit is delta x approaches zero of sine
of delta x over delta x that this is
equal to one
and we also showed another video and
that's based on the idea that this limit
is equal to one that this limit right
over here is equal to zero
and so what we are then left with and i
encourage you to watch the videos that
prove this and this although these are
really useful limits to know in general
in calculus that what you're going to be
left with is just cosine of x times 1
minus sine of x times 0 well all of this
is just going to go away and you're
going to have that is going to be equal
to
cosine of x and you are done